hi kevin o'leary here right on the set  of shark tank over shooting season six  you know be a ten-year 15 years old  happy birthday i started my television  career with you on the air with Janice  Mackey frere then she went to cover some  of the wars in the nastiest places on  earth was it me I don't know then I  started it be an end with a man delaying  who's she now the most attractive  communist on TV should I take credit for  that may be speaking about great TV  don't miss shark tank on CTV to this  year it's going to be fantastic coming  to you at nine o'clock on friday nights  be there I'll be there because I'm  making it right now happy birthday bnn  see you soon